And
if they feel that there might be any illegal
activity taking place within those transactions,
they then create a report.
They send that report to hire up, uh, management
folks.
And those folks then send it along to the
Treasury Department for a full investigation.
In these particular instances and the transactions
involving both, both Donald Trump and Jared
Cushner, these employees, the mid level ones
who manually reviewed it, did think that there
could be potential criminal activity taking
place.
They made their reports, sent it to the higher
ups and just waited on that information to
go to the treasury department, except that
it never went to the treasury department.
And that's the problem.
Those high ranking managers at Deutsche Bank
decided not to pursue it.
They thought, no, these mid level employees,
uh, they're just kind of overblowing this,
let's not worry about the potential money
laundering that they think they may have uncovered
with Donald J. Trump and Jared Cushner.
Another reason why this story is so important
is because these transactions were taking
place in 2016 when Donald Trump was running
for president.
And 2017 when Donald Trump was president.
And Jared Cushner was a senior White House
advisor for some reason.
So these were happening while the man was
president.
Of the United States, they were happening
while the man was running to be president
of the United States.
The people at the bank, at least the ones
who really looked at it, said, hold up.
Something's not right here.
What we're seeing, and this is according to
the report, is lots of money that's bouncing
back and forth between accounts.
And at least one of those accounts was with
the now defunct Trump foundation.
And that's how they described it.
Just money moving back and forth, back and
forth.
Very, very suspiciously.
Uh, same thing with Cushner and crushers accounts.
We're actually with the wealthy Russians.
So once again, it always ends up coming back
to Russian somehow or another, but that's
who Jared Kushner's accounts were bouncing
money back and forth between Deutsche Bank
in the past, uh, in fact, past couple of years,
which popped for $40 billion for laundering
money for wealthy Russians.
Now I know some people get annoyed say, oh,
enough with the Russians.
Okay, but that's the thing that happened,
that that's verifiable.
We know Deutsche Bank helped launder money
for the Russians.
That's a fact.
Except it and move on.
Yeah.
The other thing we know is that Deutsche Bank
also allowed money to flow in and out of Iran,
even though we have sanctions in place that
would prevent such transactions from taking
place.
So Deutsche Bank doing business where they're
all uh, not allowed to do business.
Deutsche Bank doing your legal business over
in Russia and, and I can't stress this one
enough.
Deutsche Bank several years ago was also find
by the Treasury Department because they didn't
follow the protocols that had been put in
place that the bank was supposed to follow
to identify potential money laundering.
So basically Deutsche Bank is the bank to
go to if you want to launder money.
Here's another piece of the puzzle here.
You have a woman by the name of Tammy Mcfadden,
one of the few people in this story who was
willing to be named.
Ms. McFadden was fired from Deutsche Bank
about a year ago after she brought it to the
attention of management at the bank that they
weren't, still weren't, by the way, following
those money laundering protocols to identify
potentially suspicious transactions.
She was fired for that.
She also happens to be one of the people who
personally saw the transactions and reviewed
them for both Donald Trump and Jared Kushner.
So here's what needs to happen right now.
It's perfectly possible that none of this
was illegal.
It's highly unlikely that none of this was
illegal.
So Ms. McFadden, who has seen this information
probably needs to pay congress a little visit.
I hope members of Congress saw this report
come out on a Sunday.
It said, you know, who would be a great person
to subpoena Tammy Mcfadden?
You know, who probably has a lot of information
that we need for the investigations were carrying
out Terry McFadden.
So do you know who we're going to send a special
invite to?
Terry McPhatter.
Tammy McFadden, excuse me.
But that's what needs to happen, folks.
Right now.
Congress is supposed to be working with Deutsche
Bank.
They were working with Deutsche Bank to get
Donald Trump's financial records until the
Trump, uh, family sued them to prevent turning
over that information, a lawsuit that is most
likely going to fail on its merits.
Just because the president cannot interfere
with the work of Congress.
They're trying to argue in court that the
reason Democrats are doing this is only for
political reasons and because it's not related
to legislation, they shouldn't have access
to this information.
Unfortunately, our system of checks and balances
does allow Congress to carry out investigations
and therefore the courts are basically going
to be powerless to stop the Democrats in their
investigations.
But in addition to the records, I do believe
that the Ms. McFadden needs the come and tell
Congress what she knows, what she saw, and
if they can convince the other folks who were
nameless in this article because they still
want to work in the industry, they said they
need to come forward as well, because I don't
think this would necessarily hurt your chances
of working in the finance industry if you
come forward and say, Hey, my boss is committing
crimes.
I know it does, and I know that's how, you
know people attack whistleblowers, but these
are people that need to be hoisted upon our
shoulders.
Right?
I mean, regardless of who it's about, it could
be about anybody in this country, not Trump
or Cushner.
If they're exposing financial crimes that
is heroic.
They know what they're risking.
And that's why most of the people in this
story chose to remain anonymous because they
don't want to be retaliated against.
They don't want to be blackballed from the
financial community, but they also want banks
to stop breaking the law.
And that is clearly what we've seen over the
years take place with Deutsche Bank.
And I don't think it's a coincidence that
Deutsche Bank was one of the only banks willing
to loan money to Donald Trump.
That's another piece of this puzzle.
You know, they gave them two and a half billion
dollars at a time when nobody else would lend
this man any money.
And we know that Deutsche Bank has a history
of helping money launderers something doesn't
add up here.
Right.
And that's what Congress is trying to find
out.
We have learned too much damning new information
about Deutsche Bank to let this itch issue
slide.
Maybe there's collusion there.
Probably not.
You know, that could all be coincidental,
but then he's like, money laundering, bank
fraud, wire fraud, tax evasion.
Yeah.
I think those are crimes that Congress definitely
needs to uncover if they exist.